foreign
age dominated by social media big Tech
has come under increasing scrutiny for
its influence on the political discourse
this leads us to ask is Big Tech
destroying democracy Nick I think it's
complicated uh right because it's it's
certainly affecting it but we might
think about this little puzzle uh that's
happening in real time right now which
is that in the United States both
Republican Conservative Republican
legislators and liberal or Progressive
Democratic legislators are talking about
breaking up Facebook about uh you know
it has too much power it's doing things
in a way the government needs to either
own it or control it or somehow play a
bigger role at the same time in Vladimir
Putin's Russia he is trying to ban
Facebook because he finds that it is
something that he cannot control
properly
um so you know in Russia it seems like
Facebook is actually playing a role for
Democrat democracy or at least let's
call it political descent in the United
States it's seen as one of the main
problems in having a vital democracy
part of this is because uh Facebook's
role in elections in America which have
been hotly contested at least since 2000
when you know 5 000 votes separated who
became president to the 2016 election to
you know completely meritless uh charges
of fraud in the 2020 election Facebook's
role in that is not as big as anybody
thinks I think you know when you look at
where all of the funding goes where
people actually develop their political
allegiances that's all through
traditional media
um it's not even really through cable
media and things like that so I think
there's a huge amount of demonization of
big Tech going on because various people
for various reasons want to control it
to their ends I think the good news is
that Facebook is a flattening Beast this
is one of the reasons why it is moving
into the metaverse uh this is a it is
not as powerful or as you know it's not
a single car you can drive in One
Direction and I think what we're seeing
in uh initiatives uh that Twitter and
other companies are doing moving to
decentralized uh essentially uh sent uh
types of models where no one person is
going to be able to direct or censor
things that's going to be the future I
suspect we'll talk about that in a
little bit but big Tech is not
destroying democracy by any what it is
on the margins I think it is empowering
people when you think of not just
Facebook but then other things like sub
stack Twitter new forms of decentralized
communication all of that fits under the
big Tech rubric and it's actually
bringing new voices being able to talk
in secret in public and have influence
and that should be something that we
celebrate and we should always be
worried when a government says we need
to regulate and protect the this entire
industry in the name of preserving the
status quo that should that should be a
a red alert for just about anybody in
any in any context Darren do you agree
well
in principle yes in practice no
stinks are completely right
you know you should be wary of
governments
who want to control strategic Industries
you should be welcoming to New Media
that broaden participation
and you should also be somewhat tolerant
of tech because throughout history it
has been
often not always often
an engine of uh economic and other types
of progress
but often not always is the key
so as
economists
and sometimes as the American public
we tend to think that technology is a
Force for good
we all of us here I can see we've all
come of age
in the Heyday of technological optimism
in one sort or another but when you
actually look at history technology has
always a dark side as well as an
enlightening site
that dark side creates inequality
it enables companies to cut wages
without creating opportunities for
workers
it enables governments sometimes
corporations to dominate markets it can
produce weapons or new means of control
and I think one of the most contested
parts of human history for at least the
last 10 000 years is who controls
technology so I think
Nick's narrative
has
a lot
to recommend
until we come to the question of who
controls technology I think Nick given
his sort of sensibilities would also be
uncomfortable if a few corporations
controlled technology
and also especially once we recognize
that technology has this dark side so I
actually worry more about the future of
technology than the present
you know with artificial intelligence
who is going to control work whether we
destroy jobs for everybody or we create
jobs for lots more people Nick is right
that Facebook did not create today's
polarization or the uh poisonous
atmosphere that exists in the US and
many other countries but inequality
is he's a huge part of it and I think we
cannot understand today's inequalities
without recognizing the role that
digital technologies have had in that
automation
is a key part of it is what my research
emphasizes and Ai and how the future of
technology is going to be shaped by
corporations or by Chinese government is
going to be a critical part of it
absolutely I think social media can be
enormous good
if it empowers people
but neither Facebook nor none of the
other
Giants are investing in empowering
people
they are very willing to manipulate
people's opinion
and provide governments the tools to
monitor over people but they're not
really as willing to invest in
encryption or other ways of private
Communications
you know Facebook repeatedly
shows if you look at the evidence
a complete disregard for the political
Fallout freedom of speech human rights
at the EXP when it comes to a trade-off
between that and increasing user
engagement so all of these things make
me worry about what the future of
technology is going to be and I cannot
but reach the conclusion that you need a
power significant enough to be a counter
railing Force against big Tech and I
don't see any other candidate than the
government it's not the Chinese
government it's not the Russian
government because they are not embedded
in a democratic context and perhaps in
the future American government won't be
either
but if we believe
that democratic governments can actually
make
choices that are both based on expertise
and in line with the interests and
vision of the people I think we have to
also welcome
efforts to study and understand how we
can control technology and not just
leave it in the hands of a handful of
people I want to bring beta in a moment
but Nick let me let you quickly come
back on that because
um can we trust government to act in the
best interests of the people that's
control technology questions yeah I
think Darren raises a really good point
that kind of should inform everything
we're talking about we talk about
government you know as one big category
corporations as one big category people
uh or you know the polis as one big
category there's a world of difference
between the American government and the
Chinese government
um and you know we need to take that
into account we need to understand that
certain corporations act in
fundamentally different ways
um I what I worry about particularly in
a western context and particularly in an
American and a European context when
we're talking about freedom of speech is
that the government's here and certain
types of activists are leveraging the
fears of governments like Russia's and
China's to come up with a system of
control of media and of speech and of
expression and of privacy in the west
where it's completely virtually
completely uncalled for if we are
talking about fears of the future
um you know of Facebook aligning with
the government or you know something
similar to that in creating a social
credit system because China is doing it
we're doing real damage to the limits on
government that we have placed and that
I think we all uphold and want
um in the name of fending off something
that is not quite happening here so it's
it's worth
thinking about you know where are we
talking about and how does intervention
uh you know by the government or by
other people come into play I think the
other just very quickly the other point
I would make is that you know the
question of say Monopoly power is not
necessarily a question of the mere uh
percentage of an industry that accompany
one or two firms controls but it's
whether or not there are barriers to
entry whether or not people can leave or
whether or not the the major firms are
acting as if they are under competition
so you know there are times you know
standard oil at the peak of its market
share it was charging the least in
America anyway it was charging the least
for its product ever uh so you know
that's maybe that's not a perfect
outcome but it's a com it's more
complicated than saying any firm that
has 75 85 90 of a market should be
broken up by a government which is
acting in the people's best interests
oftentimes times interventions into the
market are either done for Pure politics
reasons or they're being egged on by
competitors uh competitor firms and they
don't actually make consumers or
citizens or individuals any better off
yeah that's actually a good point to
bring you in
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas